it really is a science of moral dynamics
or normative dynamics right and that and
and game theorists do it take let's take
a really simple case in the case of
moral progress which was really fast
right and but and the game theory I
think in this case is very very simple
then indirect most cases are more
complicated in the strategic dynamics
and therefore the game models are more
complicated but here's a real simple one
before World War 2 New Guinea
Highlanders each tribe lived in a valley
and the structure of the equilibrium was
every tribe was permanently at war with
every other tribe right
each tribe lived in its own valley you
could leave your valley because because
what would happen to you if another
tribe called you was they would kill you
right and everybody would kill anyone
from any other tribe that they found
well so from time to time tribes would
have to force up for foraging reasons
take risky trips up the mountains but
then they might bump into people from
the other tribe and there would be
bloodshed ah the it's in equilibrium
right who knows whether there were some
moral heroes among some New Guinea
Highlanders who who would sit around the
campfire and say this Jesus seems
wasteful and terrible wouldn't it be
nice to go up and enjoy the view from
the top of the mountain in peace but
nobody can do anything about it cuz it's
in equilibrium right if you can't change
it by yourself you can't even know ten
people can change it World War two comes
along and there's a flood of American
and Australian service people all over
the island who among other things
prevent where they happen to come along
where they happen to have made camp they
prevent people from valleys from killing
each other ah
right so now actually right it is
possible for some people from some
tribes to go wandering around in the
mountains and not get killed the
equilibrium is now different right we've
introduced an exogenous shock from
outside we've changed the game dynamics
there's a different equilibrium ah at
that point of course there's also an
exam for for those tribes who don't have
the benefit of American and Australian
soldiers around there's the benefit of
being able to to as it were
I'll stand what's going on over at the
next mountain where people are no longer
killing each other and to suggest you
know we could look look it's a possible
equilibrium they're not is this other
possible equilibrium in one generation
right the war of all against all was
offered so very very for me would take
moral progress and it probably was more
progress in the sense that you know if
you're in that first equilibrium only a
very very rare event only a very very
tiny proportion of people are going to
be moral heroes right and either try to
persuade their fellows that there's a
better equilibrium or even more
heroically risk their own lives trying
to change it now and so what do will
people do they'll rationalize it right
this is the equilibrium we're actually
in they'll tell stories according to
which this is the right way to live
because you it is the way you're going
to live it's more comfortable to think
that the way you actually live is the
best is a good way to live so you'll
tell us that but but then one generation
there nobody's telling that story
anymore right and and and you know
what's up this is a very simple game the
the the math of writing how we get one
equilibrium and moved and and then
thanks to the exogenous shock get to
another equilibrium is not challenging
in real cases where the moral change is
more complex you know if somebody's
trying to write a game theoretic model
of the of the know I did a game theory
model a few years ago of the way in
which society turned against the Western
society turned to get smoking right but
a little more complicated but you know
then it's not clearly a moral case
either although it's got obviously
normative partly and heavily Prudential
but you know these are the game theory
is there really isn't a good technology
for describing these kinds of dynamics
and there's lots of papers out there
that do it there's not gonna give us
reason to be optimistic about a steady
wrap-up the moral improvement look if if
very very bad things surely we all we
all think well recognize that if really
really bad things happen to
the world economy we would prompt there
would be moral regression right I mean
right I mean sound moral behavior is is
costly often good and we're in better
form we're in a much better position to
do it when we've got our asset bases in
good shape
morality is something that we can afford
in circumstances of what Hume called
moderate scarcity scarcity so is the
increasing moral improvement that we've
seen not just but it that problems
I was almost certainly a necessary
condition you know it it is written in
the case that that we need to be able to
afford quote unquote or have the
resources to be in order to be concerned
for a wider expansion of the circle
right I mean I'm concerned about animal
welfare but if I'm starving to death in
the middle of the savanna I'm gonna kill
whatever anyone comes mine mine and you
know the hell with any more welfare so I
think it's perfectly reasonable to think
that yes more moral the moral circle
expands when we have managed to build a
society that can afford that sort of
thing but I don't think that's defeating
the the model of decision making because
in fact the to go hand in hand and sort
of feed back into each other we build
better societies because we improve our
moral thinking and vice versa having a
better society improves our moral
thinking
you